(music)
(panting)
Nothing comes easy here
in our wildest frontier.
(music)
Home to some of the deadliest
animals on the planet.
(roar)
(music)
(bellows)
This is Alaska!
And you need true grit
to live here.
North America doesn't get
much colder nor any darker
than Alaska in winter.
The only way to survive here
is to go wild.
(roaring)
This is a dangerous
time of year.
It's the end of winter.
Competition for food
is at its peak.
This year's late arrival of
spring heightens the tension.
The hungry grow weaker.
A golden eagle watches
Steller's sea eagles
arriving on his patch.
They are not here to hunt;
they're here to steal.
(squawking)
But a squabble breaks out
within their gang.
An opportunity for the golden
eagle to win his food back.
He's the bigger bird,
and he's fully loaded
with razor-sharp talons.
(music)
Talons that lock in
the featherweight food fight.
(music)
The battle rages...
until the proud owner
of this patch wins it back.
Here in Alaska, only
the toughest bird survives.
(music)
After months of punishing cold,
it happens.
Light breaks through
the biggest sky in America.
(music)
Warmth finally loosens
winter's tight grip,
awakening new hungers.
Alaska's north gets as many
as 40 additional minutes
of light every day,
until there's no night at all.
Streams and rivers swell
with melted ice and snow.
Animals that have
struggled in winter
now look for
quick and easy meals
brought by spring's abundance.
But this is Alaska,
where nothing is easy.
Crabs lingering just
below the tidal mark
look like a trouble-free lunch
for a mink.
(music)
The mink is
a specialized crab hunter.
His teeth can easily
crush shell.
(music)
But the mink may have
met his match
with this large Dungeness crab.
(music)
In Alaska sometimes the prey
bites back...or pinches.
(music)
(squeaking)
So the mink has
to get creative,
taking out the enemy's
defenses, limb by limb.
(music)
Even if the mink chews off all
the legs, the crab might live.
Legs grow back.
(music)
Top predators have a reputation
for making lunch look easy.
But they must contend
with brilliant defenses
conjured by said lunch.
Exhibit A:
a 20-pound porcupine.
Slow, subdued.
No doubt tasty.
(music)
But how to get by those
nearly 30,000 quills?
What the prey lacks in speed,
it makes up for in defense.
(panting)
Each bacterium-filled quill
can pierce the wolf's skin
like a hypodermic needle
and cause major infection.
A sharp reminder
in these parts:
No meal is an easy meal.
The hunter decides the danger
far outweighs the reward...
and moves on to something
easier to swallow.
The now constant sunlight
triggers tremendous growth.
The fertile grasses beckon
great herds of caribou
here from colder
Canadian plains.
(music)
A single herd can hold
more than 120,000 caribou.
During their annual migration
they'll cover
more than 3,000 miles.
Their babies are often
born on the move
and need to to keep up
with the herd.
One separated from the pack
is a target.
(music)
This calf has lost her way.
Just what the nearby hunters
are banking on.
(music)
The calf escapes this time.
But another predator awaits...
more insidious
and harder to shake.
Perhaps the deadliest
animal of all.
Alaska's known for
its jaws, paws and claws.
But its smallest critter
may be the biggest menace.
The mosquito.
More than 35 species feast
in the endless daylight.
These mini-monsters lay dormant
all winter as eggs.
Now the tundra underfoot
turns to water,
triggering a mass hatching.
(music)
Just as caribou shed their
winter coats, they attack.
If infection sets in, it could
easily kill a baby caribou.
The mosquitoes then feast
on festering wounds.
(music)
Entire herds will reroute
their migration
just to avoid
the mosquito menace.
This group hugs the ocean
and looks for a sea breeze
to blow the buzzing
from their backs.
(music)
There's little relief, even
standing in the Arctic Ocean.
(buzzing)
Never has such a deadly
creature been just so annoying.
(music)
There's nothing left to do but
plunge into a full-body bath,
which seems to do the trick.
(music)
No animal is immune to
its bloodsucking attacks.
And as quickly as they
appeared, they vanish.
(music)
Plentiful water brings
a different kind of horde
to Alaska.
(music)
(tinkling)
The streams and rivers swell
with melted ice and snow.
By late spring,
the waterways gush.
Sockeye salmon arrive
from the Pacific.
(music)
Over 30 million of them,
swimming upriver to spawn in
the very place they were born.
(music)
Of the thousands that arrive,
only a few make it back.
They've got a lot of obstacles
on their way up--
dams, disease, fishermen.
But the last thing they want
to encounter is this guy.
The brown bear.
The ultimate predator.
(roaring)
Adult males sport four-inch
non-retractable claws
that can slash with precision.
They have three-inch
canine teeth
that grasp and tear flesh.
Brown bears are among the
strongest creatures on Earth.
And strength needs fuel...
lots of it.
After months of slim pickings,
it's time for a fish feast.
These bears need
a protein boost, fast.
(music)
This is where rank
in brown bear hierarchy
matters most.
A rocky outcrop, midway across,
is one of the best fishing
positions on the river.
Control of this perch gives
its owner a critical advantage.
(music)
Here, fishing requires
virtually no effort.
(music)
It's possible to pack on pounds
and save energy
at the same time.
(music)
Downstream, a mother bear
and her cubs
approach the good spot.
(music)
The growing cubs
need the protein,
but this is a dangerous place
for them.
(music)
Aggressive males can injure
or even kill them.
(music)
The swift current separates
the mother from her young.
(squawking)
(music)
An older male seizes
his opportunity...
and attacks.
(music)
He could easily
slaughter the cubs.
But mother steps in.
(roaring)
At this moment, she may be the
most dangerous bear in Alaska.
The older male outweighs her
by 500 pounds.
(roar)
But he knows not to mess
with a mother's fury.
And he has more important
things to worry about,
like maintaining his position
above the falls.
During the fight,
the older male lost
his prized fishing spot.
Young challengers have
seized the opportunity
and moved in on his turf.
(music)
Now, the balance of power
teeters above the falls.
The older bear
has more experience
but is weakened
by his fighting.
(music)
(roar)
This younger, stronger rival
seizes his chance
to oust the older bear.
(roaring)
(music)
(roar)
(roaring)
(music)
The fallen king is chased
further downstream.
(music)
A loss of rank could mean
the loss of life,
especially during
the salmon run,
when the window of opportunity
will soon abruptly shut.
Such is the hardship
for Alaskan predators
whose warm weather bounty lasts
but a blink of an eye.
The Arctic fox is looking
forward to summer,
however brief.
His icy wasteland transforms
into a land of possibilities.
(music)
All requiring stealth.
Step one: a new wardrobe.
Get rid of the white winter fur
coat to match the new terrain.
Now he's an expert
at hiding in plain sight.
The goal is to catch
most of a year's prey
in a very short window of time.
(howling)
It will make or break him.
Suddenly, a feast arrives.
Millions of migratory birds
turn his island
into an Easter basket.
(music)
One lost egg tastes good.
Imagine a whole nest.
(music)
But getting at the mother lode
can be tricky.
Because of, well, mothers...
and fathers.
(music)
(squawking)
Arctic terns are
fearless parents.
(music)
(cheeping)
These birds can draw blood.
(music)
(squawking)
And they'll even
peck out his eyes.
(music)
The Arctic fox
dodges his attackers.
But he still needs to meet
a huge quota of prey.
(music)
He's hunting for six.
So he avoids the vigilantly
protected nest all together.
And goes right for the chick.
A bird in the mouth is worth
at least a dozen eggs.
Another predator that stalks
these barren lands
is 100 times larger
than the fox
with an appetite to match.
(music)
And unlike
her brown bear cousins,
polar bears don't hibernate,
they hunt year-round.
In winter, polar bears eat
seals that live on the ice.
(music)
But come spring,
they are nowhere to be found.
So, she must go far and wide
to find something to eat.
A polar bear's search for food
is even harder
in a warming climate.
The farther she must swim,
the hungrier she gets.
(music)
A lucky break
for the polar bear.
The sea has done
her work for her.
A washed-up whale carcass.
It's an amazing sight:
27 tons of blubber.
(music)
(squawking)
It's an all-you-can-eat
blubber buffet
and her first bite of
substantial food in months.
Amazingly, it could feed her
for a whole year.
But that's if she
has it to herself.
Other ice bears have
the same idea.
(music)
The small bears
are enthusiastic.
They're still nursing, but
also need their fill of fat.
(music)
And suddenly,
a huge male appears.
His hunger is
as big as his bark.
(grunting)
A smaller mother bear isn't
happy about the intrusion...
and tries to teach him
a lesson.
(roaring)
(music)
(grunting)
(birds squawking)
He sneaks in
from another angle.
But he's told to wait his turn.
(panting)
Once the others
have had their fill,
the male is finally given
permission to lick the fat.
After months of summer, the
sunshine is no longer endless.
And chilly, misty mornings
mark the arrival of autumn
and the return of giants.
A moose bull in his prime
shows off his splendid antlers.
(music)
He jousts loudly
with vegetation
for the benefit of cows
and fellow bulls alike.
(rustling)
The biggest racks actually
make a different sound
than the smaller ones,
announcing size and status to
anyone who might be listening.
The females take notice.
Other bulls
entering their prime
and bearing equally
impressive headgear
are drawn to
the scent of the cows.
(music)
The stage is awash
in testosterone,
and trouble can't be
far behind.
The bulls are ready to rumble.
(music)
With the rut in full swing,
a come-hither look
from a moose cow
brings the dominant bull
running.
(music)
The females are getting
more and more receptive,
showing their approval
of the big bull's status
by contributing their
pheromone-laden urine
to his rut pits.
(music)
With his exquisitely
sensitive nose,
he checks on a cow's readiness.
He seems pleased
with the results.
(groans)
At 11 years old, he is truly a
picture of a bull in his prime.
1,500 pounds, seven feet high
at the shoulder,
with a six-foot rack.
It's no wonder the cows
like what they see!
But there's trouble
on the horizon.
A younger and equally
impressive bull.
(music)
The challenger approaches,
waving his great antlers
from side to side.
The master responds.
These rituals of intimidation
are usually enough
to determine who will dominate,
thus avoiding the risk
of injury in a fight.
(music)
The females have a keen
interest in the outcome.
(music)
Like prize fighters,
they stare each other down,
circle and wait for an opening.
Neither is backing down.
(music)
(clattering)
With equally matched bulls,
the battle may last
up to a half an hour or more.
(music)
But the older bull soon
gains the upper hand.
He batters the challenger
unmercifully.
(bellows)
(music)
Abruptly,
the contest is decided.
The master will return
to his harem.
The younger one paid the price
for his bid to reproduce.
In this unforgiving place,
his wounded leg may spell doom.
The victor has urgent business
to tend to.
(music)
And just in time.
Fall is on the way out.
Winter comes early this year.
(music)
Record snowfall gives
deep cover for rodents...
like the vole.
(music)
Hidden beneath, they are
protected from the cold
and hunters above.
(music)
(squeak)
The vole's ears are big and
can listen out for danger.
But what good is that
if danger makes no sound?
(music)
Silence is the snowy owl's
secret weapon.
(music)
Fringed edges of
her flight feathers
break up the flapping noise
that a normal bird makes.
(music)
And her attack
is as silent as death.
(music)
The vole never knew
what hit him.
(music)
Snow is a problem
for predator and prey alike,
mostly because it makes sound.
But Alaska's creature have come
up with ingenious workarounds.
(music)
The red fox has perfected
the hunt below and above.
(music)
At only 10 pounds, he doesn't
break the snow's surface.
(music)
So he can search for prey
without detection.
But his prey hides
below the surface.
So how do you find
what you cannot see?
Big ears and magnetic senses.
Synced together,
these secret weapons
make the red fox
a stealth hunter,
able to catch his victims
under nearly two feet of snow.
First he pinpoints
the faintest sound.
Then homes in on the sweet spot
where the angle of the sound
matches the slope of
the planet's magnetic field.
Once the fox locks on
to that spot,
he can calculate the exact
distance to his prey.
In this case, a meadow vole.
But then what?
(music)
(rustling)
If he digs, the vole will flee.
So instead, he flies.
(music)
(sniffing)
(snarling)
(music)
A small bite,
but in winter
every calorie counts.
Alaska's snows inspire
a million ways
for hunters to innovate.
One of those ways is to
stop hunting altogether.
And start scavenging.
The wolverine's nose
leads the way,
sniffing out prey
and hibernating animals
buried more than 20 feet
beneath the snow.
(music)
This dog-sized weasel
is able to take down
a full-grown caribou.
But today, this wolverine
is saving his energy.
He's found a frozen dinner.
(music)
It takes the keenest nose
to pick up the scent
of a carcass in winter.
Wolverines outmatch most
other animals with this skill.
But then they have to contend
with each other.
Within minutes,
the competition arrives.
(music)
This is when the true wolverine
nature kicks in to the max.
(music)
(growling)
The semi-retractable claws
come out.
The specialized teeth
are bared.
It's all-out war.
The defender gets
the upper claw...
(snarling)
...and wins his meal back.
(music)
Powerful jaws break down
the entire animal,
including hooves,
teeth and bones.
This is his turf and his food;
food that was supposed
to be convenient.
But this is deadly Alaska
where the challenges are epic.
(music)
Animals like the wolverine
don't just survive
the tough environment,
they thrive because of it.